Do you ever imagine your own funeral?
I do.
In fact,
it may be something I think about a little bit
too much,
given my age and health and happiness.
But as someone with an interest in liturgy and an inclination towards self-reflection,
imagining and even planning my own funeral
is a fascinating possibility.
Will prayers that I have written be used?
Will there be liturgical dance?
What photos will surface?
Who will attend?
Who will speak?
And most importantly,
what will they say?
I hope they will say that I loved.
They may speak about my academic. Not irritable or resentful.
It does not rejoice in wrongdoing but rejoices in the truth.
Love bears all things, believes all things, hopes
all things. Love
the never ends.
We could bask in the beauty of Paul's ode to love all day.
This is an incredibly evocative description
of love.
And for many of us it brings to mind romantic
love.
This passage is often read at weddings.
And with February 14th only two weeks
away,
we are surrounded by eternal devotion
declared on candy hearts, shop windows full of pink, pre-packaged
romance, and
invitations to speed dating at Gypsy.
But Paul is writing about more than romantic
love. He is writing about the love of a whole community.
A community composed of people very different
from one another,
poor and rich,
female and male,
liberal and conservative,
politically, socially, and theologically.
And Paul is exhorting them all to love one another.
When we listen to this description of love with this context in
mind, we realize how difficult and demanding real love is.
Love is
patient. Love is kind.
Love is not envious, boastful, arrogant or rude.
Love does not insist on its own way.
Love is not irritable or resentful.
Love does not rejoice in wrongdoing, but rejoices in the truth.
Love bears all
things, believes all things, hopes all things, endures all
things. Love never ends. Is there no escape?
Suddenly love has become a lot more challenging.
Suddenly love is not a warm fuzzy feeling,
or even a deep abiding commitment.
Suddenly love is about everything we do,
everything we think, everything we feel,
our attitudes, our habits, our actions, our beliefs, our hopes.
Love is demanded in every aspect of our lives.
And love is not only about one romantic partner,
but about everyone,
friends,
family,
enemies,
the people we don't even know exist.
This radical love described by Paul is mysterious.
We can only know it in part.
We can only see it through a mirror dimly.
We can only glimpse shadowy reflections
of this love,
but these shadowy reflections are the most important thing in the world.
We can glimpse this live by looking at the people in our
lives and in our faith traditions who embody love.
We
can glimpse this love by telling the real love stories.
My former pastor and colleague Joel
showed me what it means to love in the most mundane and ordinary moments.
Joel took time with each person he encountered
to make that person feel like they mattered -
the custodian at church,
the photographer at the reception,
the other passenger in the elevator,
the quiet youth on the fringes of the church youth group,
and the rebel who everyone else had already
given up on.
Joel was often late.
And I will admit that people who are late normally really annoy me,
but with Joel, it didn't bother me quite as much,
because I suspected that he was late because he had stopped
to listen to someone
who needed to talk or taking that extra moment to acknowledge that the service worker was a person, not a machine.
Love is patient,
love is kind.
Love takes time for people
no matter what.
Who has shown you love that is patient
and kind?
Jesus returned to his
hometown, stood up in front of the religious community that raised him
and declared,  "I am the fulfillment of Scripture.
I am the Messiah."
We heard about this in the glorious gospel
reading last week
and this week we heard the results.
Members of jesus community ran him out of town
and threatened to throw him off a cliff.
This is the good news of the gospel.
Love is about speaking the truth,
even when it's risky.
Love is about saying the things that you just
aren't supposed to say.
Love is not always about being nice.
Love rejoices in the truth,
even the hard truth
no matter what.
Who has given you a glimpse of love that rejoices
in the truth?
This community at University Church
has also taught me about love.
You are some of the most talented and impressive
people I have ever met.
I tremble at the thought of your resumes.
And soon many of you will have a label permanently attached to your name
that will declare to the world you are exceptional.
At the same time
you have shown me what it means to love in
ways that are not boastful or
arrogant or rude.
Some of you have shown love through the questions you ask
and your readiness to learn.
Some of you have love through your openness
to trying new things,
even things you might not be good at.
Some of you have shown love through your willingness
to help out with no expectation of recognition or reward.
Love is not boastful or arrogant or rude.
Love is
humble no matter what you have accomplished.
Who has given you a glimpse of humble love?
My grandma and grandpa were married in 1942.
I remember the huge party celebrating their
50th wedding anniversary in
1992.
I had a brand new pink dress and helped to decorate their cars with colorful flowers and streamers.
Over the following 10 years my grandfather's
health began to fail.
My grandparents moved out of their house and into a condo.
Eventually my grandfather moved into the nursing
home next door.
My Grandfather, my grandmother walked over
every day to visit him.
When my grandparents celebrated their 61st
wedding anniversary in
2003,
both my grandmother and grandfather were very
ill.
The night before my grandmother died
she had a lucid moment and a nurse recorded her words.
She spoke of her love for her children and
grandchildren
and of her love for her husband,
even though he could no longer read the newspaper.
At first
I found these last words tragic.
My grandmother's final thoughts of my grandfather
were about how he was no longer the man
he used to be.
Now I hear it differently.
My grandmother's last words were about how much she loved my grandfather
despite
and because he was no longer the man she had
married 61 years before.
Within a week of my grandmother's death,
my grandfather also passed away.
After more than six decades, how could they
be apart?
Love endures.
Love survives challenge and change
no matter what
Who has given you a glimpse of love that
endures?
Dirk Willams
was one of my forebears in
faith in the Mennonite faith tradition.
He was a sixteenth-century church leader
in the Netherlands who was imprisoned on account
of his beliefs.
After being imprisoned for a year Dirk escaped.
He was pursued across a frozen river by a prison
guard
and after he had safely reached the far bank
he heard a loud crack
behind him.
The ice had broken and the guard had fallen
through into the frigid water.
Dirk hesitated for only a second
before turning around,
inching across the ice,
and extending his hands to his captor.
He pulled the guard safely to shore.
And the guard wanted to let Dirk go,
but his supervisor arrived and called out to
him to hold Dirk.
The guard returned Dirk to prison
and he was burned at the stake several months
later.
Dirk Willams died for
his faith, a faith that taught him that the lives of his enemies were worth saving,
even at the cost of his own life.
Love does not insist on its own way.
Love puts the other person first
no matter what.
Who has given you a glimpse of
love that does not insist on its own way?
After hearing these
stories, how can I even hope to embody a fraction of
the love lived out by these individuals
and communities>
How could I presume to suggest that at my funeral
people would celebrate that I loved?
I am overwhelmed by my own failure to love
and by a world that so often seems so inhospitable to love.
And then I remember
that love is not all about me.
Sometimes it may feel like it's all about me -
my feelings, my thoughts, my desires, my actions.
But love is not all about me.
At other times it feels like love is all about other people,
about putting the feelings, thoughts, desires, and actions of others first.
But love is not all about other people either.
Love is all about God.
Love is all about God being all about everyone.
It is about God loving other people and God loving me and
especially about God bringing you and me and us and them together.
Because love is all about God being all about
everyone, love can never be separated from justice
or forgiveness.
Regardless of what I believe in this moment
about God and whether
God exists,
or is powerful or is good, love is still about God.
Love is something beyond and within us, something that moves us towards one another,
something that moves us towards our most honest selves.
This kind of God,
this kind of love is something to celebrate.
God's love revealed in human love is something to celebrate.
So we celebrate the love of Joel and Jesus
and University Church and my grandparents and
Dirk and all of the other people who have given us
glimpses of God's love.
We celebrate love that is patient and kind,
love that rejoices in the truth,
love that is humble,
love that endures, love that does not insist on its own way, love that bears
all things, believes all things, hopes all things,
love that never ends.
We celebrate God's love reflected in human love in every moment of life,
love present when sperm meets egg,
when lungs meet air,
when parents meet child, when child meets friends, when youth meet enemies,  when people meet passions, when partner meets
partner,
when age meets wisdom,
when body meets earth,
when spirit meets spirit.
Love never ends.
This is the type of love I hope friends and family will celebrate at my funeral.
This is the type of love I hope to celebrate in every moment of my life.
This is the type of love I hope our life together can celebrate.
God is this love. This is God's love. Amen.